OK, so there's this couple. They've been married for years, had two kids, when they decided to separate. They get lawyers, start to figure out custody and split the property. But they're still living in the same house, and the guy is hoping that they're going to work things out. They're going to marriage counseling. They're going to parenting classes.
好的，有一对夫妻。他们结婚多年，有两个孩子，后来决定分居。他们找了律师，开始处理监护权和财产分割问题。但他们仍住在同一栋房子里，男方还希望他们能重归于好。他们去参加婚姻咨询，去上育儿课程。
And then one Saturday, the guy spots a text message on his wife's phone from another man to his wife saying, "I love you and miss you." And he's devastated. And he turns to someone he knows will be on his side, will help him make sense of this, tell him what to do-- his lawyer. The guy who represents him in the separation.
后来在一个星期六，男方在妻子的手机上看到另一名男子发来的短信，上面写着“我爱你，想你”。他崩溃了。他向一个他认为会站在自己这边、帮助他理清这一切并告诉他该怎么做的人寻求帮助——那就是他的律师。那个在分居诉讼中代表他的男人。
What he didn't know was that his lawyer was probably, at that moment, the single worst person in the world for him to be bringing this up with because, as he later learned, the man his wife was having an affair with was his lawyer. Of course, once the husband figures out the truth, he gets a new lawyer. The old lawyer ends up being charged with professional misconduct.
他不知道的是，当时那个律师可能是世界上最不适合跟他谈论这件事的人，因为他后来得知，与他妻子有染的人正是这位律师。当然，一旦丈夫弄清了真相，他就换了一位新律师。而那位旧律师最终因职业不当行为受到指控。
I have right here the transcript of that disciplinary hearing. Because the family's been through enough already with this, I'm not going to give their names here on the radio or tell you where this happened. They have moved on. I will just call them Mr. And Mrs. X.
我手里就有那次纪律听证会的记录。因为这个家庭已经为此饱受折磨，我不会在广播中透露他们的姓名，也不会说这件事发生在哪里。他们已经翻篇了。我就称他们为X先生和X太太。
And this transcript is an amazing document, because when you read it, you realize it's even worse than you would imagine. Like, it sounds bad, and the details make it even worse, because a lawyer, you know, is not just like a business consultant who you hire to deal with your paperwork. A lawyer is really a confidant.
这份记录是一份了不起的文件，因为当你阅读它时，你会发现情况比你想象的还要糟糕。听起来很糟糕，而细节让它变得更糟，因为律师你知道，不仅仅是你雇来处理文书工作的商务顾问。律师其实是一个知己。
The Monday after he learns of the affair, Mr. X goes to his lawyer's office and pours out his heart about what's happened. At that point, Mr. X doesn't know who his wife might be seeing but suspects a firefighter in town. This is from the hearing transcript.
得知婚外情的那个周一，X先生去律师办公室，倾诉了所发生的一切。那时，X先生不知道妻子可能在和谁交往，但怀疑是镇上的一名消防员。这是听证会记录里的内容。
Quote, "I'm sitting with the lawyer for an hour explaining to him how I can't believe she's having an affair, that I think it's the fireman. And he's looking at me right in the face. I'm in tears crying to him, you know? Because I never thought she would have an affair on me. And here, he's right in front of me. He's the guy that's having an affair with my wife."
引用如下：“我坐在律师对面一个小时，向他解释我不敢相信她竟然出轨了，我以为是那个消防员。他正面对着我。我泪流满面地对他哭诉，你知道吗？因为我从没想过她会背叛我。而此时此刻，他就坐在我面前。他就是那个和我妻子有私情的男人。”
The person questioning Mr. X asks, "What's he saying to you?"
询问X先生的人问：“他对你说了什么？”
Mr. X, "Nothing. He didn't say nothing. He didn't even seem to care I was there."
X先生说：“什么也没说。他什么也没说。他看起来甚至都不在乎我在那儿。”
It gets even worse. Specifically, when they deal with the question of payment, which really boils down to if your attorney has an affair with your wife who is also, at the same time, the opposing party in the case, do you get a refund for that? The $1,500 that you paid your lawyer, do you get that back?
更糟糕的是。具体来说，当他们处理付款问题时，这实际上归结为：如果你的律师与同时也是该案对方当事人的你的妻子发生了婚外情，你还能拿到退款吗？你付给律师的1500美元，你能拿回来吗？
In this hearing, the lawyer was actually given a chance to question the witnesses himself, which led to a totally surreal moment in which, under oath, the lawyer actually cross-examined Mr. X, the client whose wife he had an affair with. The lawyer says to Mr. X, quote, "When we talked about returning the fee that you paid me, isn't it true that I said I was willing to talk about it?"
在这次听证会上，律师实际上有机会亲自质询证人，这导致了一个极其超现实的时刻：在宣誓后，律师竟然交叉询问了X先生，也就是那位妻子被他勾引的客户。律师对X先生说，引用如下：“当我们谈到退还你支付给我的费用时，我没说我愿意商量一下吗？”
Mr. X-- "No. You said you earned every penny. You said, 'I had done a lot of work. And I feel like I earned all that money.' That's exactly what you said."
X先生——“没有。你说你每一分钱都挣得理所当然。你说，‘我做了很多工作。我觉得我挣的所有钱都是应得的。’你就是这么说的。”
Lawyer-- "So you don't believe you recall hearing me say that I was willing to talk about it?"
律师——“所以你不相信你记得我曾说过我愿意商量退费的事？”
Mr. X-- "No."
X先生——“不记得。”
Lawyer-- "Do you remember that I tried to apologize to you?"
律师——“你记得我试着向你道歉吗？”
Mr. X-- "Yeah, I do remember that. I asked you, 'Don't you have something to say to me?' I said, 'For everything you've done, having an affair with my wife,' I said, 'don't you at least owe me an apology for all that?' And yes, you did. You said, 'I'm sorry for all that.' Does that answer your question?"
X先生——“是的，我确实记得。我问你，‘你就没什么话要对我说吗？’我说，‘为了你所做的一切，和我妻子有染，’我说，‘难道你不至少欠我一个道歉吗？’是的，你道了歉。你说，‘我对所有这一切感到抱歉。’这回答你的问题了吗？”
Lawyer-- "Did you at any point feel like you could bring yourself to accept my apology?"
律师——“你有没有在某一刻觉得你能接受我的道歉？”
Mr. X-- "It's going to take a long time. I have and I pray for you every day. And I hope God has mercy on your soul. I really do."
X先生——“这需要很长时间。我已经（接受了），我每天都在为你祈祷。我希望上帝能怜悯你的灵魂。我是真心的。”
For his part, the lawyer said he never intended to hurt anyone. He was an alcoholic, he said, just coming out of a divorce himself, quote, "Lonely and not exercising good judgment." When he was asked about that moment in his office when Mr. X came in and cried, and he didn't say anything, he says, quote, "I remember feeling very awkward about it. In hindsight, I should have revealed the relationship sooner and withdrawn from the case. And I did say to her on several occasions, 'You know, I'm going to have to bow out of this case.'"
就他而言，律师说他从没想过要伤害任何人。他说他是个酒鬼，自己也刚从离婚中走出来，引用如下：“感到孤独，且判断力不佳。”当被问及X先生走进办公室哭泣而他一言不发的那一刻时，他说，引用如下：“我记得当时感觉非常尴尬。事后看来，我应该早点披露这段关系并退出案件。我确实有几次对她说，‘你知道，我不得不退出这个案子了。’”
The person questioning the lawyer asks, "Well, why didn't you?"
质询律师的人问：“好吧，那你为什么没退出？”
The lawyer says, "Well, to be honest, it was very awkward. It was one of those things I just wasn't sure how to bring up or when to bring up."
律师说：“老实说，这很尴尬。这是那种我不知道该怎么开口或何时开口的事情之一。”
Yes, that is an awkward thing to bring up with your client. And I think the most extraordinary part of this transcript is the part where the lawyer tries to explain himself by telling his own, sad story. Quote, "I found myself justifying aspects of the relationship in terms of positive intentions, if that makes any kind of sense at all. I hope I'm not rambling too much. I guess part of my-- part of my attraction to Mrs. X initially was that she was one of the first persons, one of the first individuals I had confessed my drinking problem. And she was just so understanding and so supportive. At the time, I couldn't believe it."
是的，这确实是件很难跟客户开口的事情。我认为这份记录中最非同寻常的部分是律师试图通过讲述他自己悲伤的故事来解释自己的那一段。引用如下：“我发现自己从积极意图的角度来为这段关系的各个方面进行辩解，如果这听起来有道理的话。希望我没有啰嗦太多。我想我……最初被X太太吸引的部分原因是，她是我第一个倾诉饮酒问题的人之一。她非常理解，也非常支持。当时，我简直不敢相信。”
"If a girl meets a guy and finds out that he's a drunk, she should dump him, you know? Run not walk to get away from the situation. But she was very kind, very supportive. I know it looks real bad."
“如果一个女孩遇到一个男人发现他是酒鬼，她应该甩了他，你知道吗？跑都来不及，逃离那种情况。但她非常善良，非常支持。我知道这看起来真的很糟糕。”
For what he did, he was suspended for practicing law for three years. But before the suspension was over, another case came up of professional misconduct, and he was disbarred. For his part, Mr. X always regretted his choice of attorney. He said, quote, "I've never had to deal with anything through the law in my life. And I hired him as my attorney. I expected him to represent me, and he did everything but."
因为他的所作所为，他被吊销了三年的律师执业资格。但在停职期满之前，又出现了另一起职业不当行为案件，他被取消了律师资格。就X先生而言，他一直后悔自己选错了律师。他说，引用如下：“我这辈子从来没处理过任何法律事务。我雇他作为我的律师。我指望他代表我，可他所做的一切恰恰相反。”
The problem, of course, is when you sign up with an attorney or anybody else to give you advice, to be your guide, you have to trust them, right? And you put your life in their hands in some situations. And it is a huge leap of faith.
当然，问题在于当你签约律师或任何人来提供建议、作为你的向导时，你必须信任他们，对吧？在某些情况下，你把生命交到了他们手中。这是一个巨大的信任飞跃。
Today on our radio show, we have people who need help, who need advice, and who make some very unusual choices about who they take that leap of faith with. A kid runs away from home to get advice from somebody who he has never met in his life. A man in a terrible medical situation looks for a doctor and gets a world famous doctor who chooses to communicate with him only in rhyme.
今天在我们的广播节目中，我们邀请了一些需要帮助、需要建议的人，他们对选择谁来共同完成那个信任飞跃做出了一些非常不寻常的决定。一个孩子离家出走，去向一个他从未见过的人寻求建议；一个处境糟糕的病人寻找医生，却遇到了一位只用押韵方式与他交流的世界著名医生。
From WBEZ Chicago, it is This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这里是WBEZ芝加哥，这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际（PRI）分发。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act One, Just South of the Unicorns. When I was a kid, I wrote to my favorite astronauts. I wrote to my radio hero who was this funny proto-shock jock in Baltimore named Johnny Walker. And I got responses. I got satisfying responses.
第一幕，独角兽的南方。当我还是个孩子的时候，我给我最喜欢的宇航员写信。我给我最喜欢的电台英雄写信，那是个叫约翰尼·沃克（Johnny Walker）的滑稽的初代震动派电台主持人，他在巴尔的摩。我得到了回复。我得到了令人满意的回复。
It doesn't seem so strange at that age to reach out to people who you idolize, no matter how far away they seem. Logan Hill has the story of somebody doing just that.
在那个年纪去接触你崇拜的人，无论他们看起来多么遥远，似乎并不奇怪。洛根·希尔（Logan Hill）讲述了有人正是这样做的故事。
In the winter of 1987, my middle school in rural North Carolina was preparing for an event called The Night of the Notables. For one night only, the members of the sixth and seventh grade would dress up as historic figures and mingle. The parents would try to guess who we were.
1987年的冬天，我位于北卡罗来纳州农村的初中正在准备一场名为“名人之夜”的活动。只此一晚，六年级和七年级的学生要装扮成历史人物并进行交流。家长们会试着猜出我们是谁。
Each kid picked a notable-- Lincoln, Washington, Harriet Tubman. When it was my turn, the 12-year-old me said, "Piers Anthony." My teacher, Mrs. Beal, gently suggested I might want to pick someone a bit more, well, notable, because parents might not read as much science fiction and fantasy as I did.
每个孩子都选了一个名人——林肯、华盛顿、哈丽特·塔布曼。轮到我时，12岁的我说：“皮尔斯·安东尼（Piers Anthony）。”我的老师比尔太太委婉地建议我可以选一个稍微，嗯，更出名的人，因为家长们可能不像我那样读那么多科幻小说和奇幻文学。
But I would not be swayed. I was so obsessed with sci-fi and fantasy that, at my 12th birthday party, I was pulled off the roller rink for reading the sci-fi book I had just unwrapped while roller skating. I read Ursula Le Guin, and Ray Bradbury, and Harry Harrison, and Harlan Ellison, and Larry Niven, and Robert Heinlein. But at 12, the author I loved above all others was Piers Anthony, who cranked out four books a year filled with heroic adventures, goofy puns, wise-cracking ogres and sexy cyborgs. I loved all of it.
但我没有被动摇。我对科幻和奇幻文学如此着迷，以至于在我12岁生日聚会上，我因为在滑旱冰时读刚拆开的科幻书而被赶出了滑冰场。我读厄休拉·勒古恩（Ursula Le Guin）、雷·布拉德伯里（Ray Bradbury）、哈里·哈里森（Harry Harrison）、哈兰·埃里森（Harlan Ellison）、拉里·尼文（Larry Niven）和罗伯特·海因莱因（Robert Heinlein）。但在12岁时，我最爱的作者是皮尔斯·安东尼，他一年产出四本书，书里充满了英勇的冒险、愚蠢的双关语、爱开玩笑的食人魔和性感的半机械人。我爱死这一切了。
But what made Piers Anthony so different and so remarkable was that at the end of those books about alternate dimensions and apocalypses narrowly avoided, he would often write these rambling confessional author's notes. They'd run 30, sometimes 40 pages, and they'd rarely be about the novels.
但皮尔斯·安东尼之所以如此与众不同、如此非凡，是因为在那些关于替代维度和险些避免的末日的书结尾，他经常会写这些漫无边际的自白式的作者随笔。它们能写30页，有时40页，而且很少是关于小说内容的。
Instead, Piers Anthony would write about everyday life at his Florida home and what he dubbed mundania-- his tree farm, his vegetarianism, his martial arts exercise routines. There were stories about his daughters, his wife, and the horse in his backyard name Blue that became the inspiration for a unicorn in one novel and a magical horse called The Nightmare in another.
相反，皮尔斯·安东尼会写他在佛罗里达家中的日常生活，他称之为“凡俗世界”——他的树苗场、他的素食主义、他的武术锻炼常规。还有关于他的女儿、他的妻子以及他后院那匹名叫“蓝色”的马的故事，那匹马后来成了他一部小说中独角兽的灵感来源，也是另一部小说中被称为“梦魇”的魔法马的灵感来源。
The notes were personal, like a grown-up's diary-- clashes with publishers, family illnesses, daily responsibilities. I studied them to the point that I still remember when he upgraded his computer to MS-DOS and doubled his RAM from 256k to 512k. "When I write to you," he wrote once, "it is as if we are in privacy booth, and we are sharing things that neither of us would confess elsewhere."
这些随笔很私密，就像一个成年人的日记——与出版商的冲突、家庭疾病、日常琐事。我研究它们到了我至今仍记得他何时将电脑升级到MS-DOS并将内存从256k增加到512k的程度。“当我写信给你时，”他曾写道，“就像我们在私密隔间里，分享着我们都不会在别处坦白的事情。”
I was sure Piers Anthony would help me impersonate him at the Night of the Notables. So I wrote him the first and only fan letter of my life. And he immediately responded with what seemed to be an Arc of the Covenant sized crate-- an amazing box filled with new books, his unpublished memoir, Bio of an Ogre , and a long, kind letter that wished me luck on my big night.
我确信皮尔斯·安东尼会帮我在“名人之夜”扮演他。所以我写了我一生中唯一的一封粉丝信。他立刻回信了，寄来了一个足有约柜那么大的板条箱——一个塞满了新书、他未出版的回忆录《食人魔传》，以及一封长长、亲切的信，祝我在那个盛大的夜晚好运。
When that night came, I wore a fake beard cut from a scratchy carpet remnant, plus jam surfer shorts and flip-flops since I figured that's what they wore in Florida. In the school library, I told parents I was originally from England, but I built this awesome writing studio in my backyard. And my novel, Ogre, Ogre , was the first fantasy paperback original on the New York Times bestseller list.
那晚到来时，我戴着从粗糙地毯边角料剪下来的假胡子，穿着果酱冲浪短裤和人字拖，因为我想这大概就是他们在佛罗里达穿的。在学校图书馆，我告诉家长们我最初来自英国，但我已经在后院建了一个很棒的写作室。而我的小说《食人魔，食人魔》是《纽约时报》畅销书排行榜上第一本奇幻平装原创小说。
I bragged that I'd written some 80 books, and I was so famous that my novels were on sale at the Walden Books across from the Food Lion. My teacher was right. Not a single one of these muggles could guess who I was. Steven King, one parent guessed. Star Trek, guessed another. That's not even a person, I thought.
我吹嘘说我写了大约80本书，我还如此出名，以至于我的小说在Food Lion超市对面的Walden书店都有售。老师说对了。这些“麻瓜”中没一个人猜出我是谁。一位家长猜是斯蒂芬·金（Steven King）。另一个猜是《星际迷航》。我心想，那根本不是一个人。
Somehow, I don't remember being embarrassed in the least about my choice. I don't remember the slightest hint of regret. In fact, I remember sipping sparking apple juice through my itchy beard with a 12-year-old Harriet Tubman and feeling kind of smug about the whole thing. And if nobody knew who I was, that was their problem.
不知何故，我不记得对自己选的角色感到丝毫尴尬。我不记得有任何后悔的迹象。事实上，我记得隔着发痒的胡子啜饮苹果汽水，身边站着12岁的哈丽特·塔布曼，对这一切感到有些自鸣得意。如果没人知道我是谁，那是他们的问题。
For a night, I'd walked in my favorite writer's flip-flops. And for years, I thought that had to make me his biggest fan.
那一晚，我穿着我最喜欢的作家的鞋子走了一遭。多年来，我一直认为这一定让我成了他最大的粉丝。
10 years after the Night of the Notables, I first met my friend Andy. It was the summer of 1997. I'd gone to the coast of Georgia for a wedding. A bunch of friends of the couple, barely out of college, had gone out early to party.
“名人之夜”过去10年后，我第一次见到了我的朋友安迪（Andy）。那是1997年的夏天。我去了佐治亚州沿海参加一场婚礼。那对夫妇的一群朋友，刚大学毕业，很早就去聚会了。
I was wading in the ocean with this guy Andy, a friend of the groom. At some point, it came out that I was a writer. And Andy asked me who I read when I was a kid. I could've said some hip sci-fi author like Philip K. Dick or William Gibson, but I told Andy the truth, that I'd been obsessed with this guy, Piers Anthony, who wrote about centaurs and ogres and unicorns.
我正和那个叫安迪的家伙——新郎的朋友，在海里涉水。不知怎么的，聊到了我是个作家。安迪问我小时候读谁的书。我本可以说一些时髦的科幻作家，比如菲利普·K·迪克（Philip K. Dick）或威廉·吉布森（William Gibson），但我对安迪说了实话，说我曾经迷恋这个写半人马、食人魔和独角兽的皮尔斯·安东尼。
And Andy cut me off. "Me, too!" he said. "I was obsessed." This didn't happen very often, so I got a little competitive.
安迪打断了我。“我也是！”他说。“我曾经着迷过。”这种情况并不常发生，所以我产生了一点竞争意识。
I said, "No, I was so obsessed I impersonated him." And Andy said he was more obsessed, really. And then, I one-upped him by talking about my special letter. We went back and forth, out-nerding each other until finally I blurted out, "What, you weren't the kid who ran away to his house, were you?"
我说：“不，我着迷到甚至扮演过他。”安迪说他更着迷，真的。然后，我通过谈论我那封特殊的信胜过了他。我们来回交谈，互相炫耀谁更书呆子，直到最后我脱口而出：“什么，你不是那个离家出走去他家的小孩吧？”
Actually, you said, "Were you that kid that ran away from home to visit him?" That's right. I totally remember that now.
事实上，你当时说的是：“你是那个离家出走去拜访他的小孩吗？”没错。我现在完全想起来了。
This is Andy. And the way I remember it is that after I said that, Andy just seemed sort of stunned.
这是安迪。我的记忆是，在我说出那句话后，安迪似乎有点震惊。
And what did you think about when I said that?
那你听到我那么说时在想什么？
I think I had a young person's flash of like, am I notorious? I was shocked that anybody had heard of that, because it wasn't a story and still isn't to this day-- well, I guess today being an exception-- is not a story that I've told to very many people.
我想我当时年轻，闪过一个念头：我很有名吗？我很震惊竟然有人听说过这件事，因为这并不是一个故事，直到今天依然不是——好吧，我猜今天是个例外——不是一个我告诉过很多人的故事。
The fact was I had read about Andy in Piers Anthony's office notes many years before. He'd included a couple offhand sentences about a boy who'd run away from home and showed up on his doorstep. Andy had never seen this author's note himself, but the story had stuck with me. And if I'm honest, it was probably because I was a little jealous. That same winter, when 12-year-old me was proudly dressing up in Piers Anthony drag, 15-year-old Andy was crossing seven states by himself to seek out our idol.
事实是，我早在许多年前就读过皮尔斯·安东尼作者随笔中关于安迪的内容。他随手写了几句关于一个离家出走并出现在他家门口的男孩的话。安迪自己从未见过这篇作者随笔，但这个故事留在了我心里。如果说实话，这可能是因为我有点嫉妒。就在那个冬天，12岁的我正自豪地装扮成皮尔斯·安东尼的时候，15岁的安迪正独自穿越七个州去寻找我们的偶像。
Andy's story wasn't the high-spirited adventure that I'd imagined. He doesn't like to dwell on the details of his teenage years mostly out of respect for his family. But the basic facts of his life back then are probably familiar to lot of unhappy kids.
安迪的故事并不是我想象中那种意气风发的冒险。他不太喜欢深究他少年时代的细节，主要是为了尊重他的家人。但他那时生活的基本事实可能许多不快乐的孩子都很熟悉。
Andy lived in a suburb outside Buffalo, New York. His parents had divorced when he was young, and Andy lived with his mother, half-sister, and his stepfather. His relationship with his mom wasn't good. His relationship with his stepfather, a red-blooded, corporate, athletic alpha dude, was worse.
安迪住在纽约州布法罗郊外。他的父母在他很小的时候就离婚了，安迪和母亲、同母异父的姐姐以及继父住在一起。他和母亲的关系不好。他和继父——一个血气方刚、企业化、运动型的硬汉——的关系更糟。
School was torture. Not only was he small, the smallest kid in his class even at 15, but he was weird. He liked to read books about elves. He says he had nobody to talk to, didn't have a single friend.
学校简直是折磨。他不仅个子小，哪怕到了15岁也是班里最小的孩子，而且他很怪。他喜欢读关于精灵的书。他说他没人可说话，一个朋友都没有。
By his sophomore year in 1987, Andy had so little hope of fitting in that he gave up trying. He started wearing his grandfather's 1940s fedora to school and buttoning his shirts up all the way to his neck, sometimes imagining he was from some other country, some other planet. The worse he felt, the more he retreated into fantasy until finally, like Spock slowly dematerializing on the transporter, he was barely in high school at all.
到了1987年高二的时候，安迪觉得能融入群体的希望如此渺茫，以至于他放弃了尝试。他开始戴着他祖父1940年代的软呢帽去学校，把衬衫扣子扣到脖子顶端，有时想象自己来自另一个国家，另一个星球。他感觉越糟糕，就越退缩到奇幻世界里，直到最后，就像史波克（Spock）在传送器上缓慢消失一样，他几乎不在高中了。
I just gave up. I said, "[BLEEP] it. I'm not going to do anything." So I began failing all of my classes-- like all of them. I had to repeat the 10th grade. And I'm not a dumb person. I just didn't-- actually, I would go to class. But I would just check out mentally with the help of Piers Anthony or Stephen King or whoever.
我只是放弃了。我说：“[哔]它。我什么都不做了。”所以我开始挂掉所有的课——真的是所有。我不得不重读十年级。我不是个笨蛋。我只是不——其实，我会去上课。但我会在心理上抽离，借助皮尔斯·安东尼或斯蒂芬·金或其他人的书。
And then in class, I would have the textbook. And then, inside the textbook I would have Ogre , Ogre or whatever Piers Anthony novel. At the time, I also was really into Stephen King. It came out a few years later, but I remember I read It in class all day long for like eight hours, however long you're in class, 7:00 in the morning until 3:00 in the afternoon. And I finished that 1,000 page book in like two days. That's how checked out I was.
然后在课堂上，我会拿着教科书。书里面则藏着《食人魔，食人魔》或其他什么皮尔斯·安东尼的小说。当时我也很迷斯蒂芬·金。那是几年后才出来的，但我记得我在课上整整一天都在读《它》，大约八个小时，不管你在学校呆多久，从早上7点到下午3点。我两天就读完了那本1000页的书。我当时就是这么游离的。
Like me, Andy loved Piers Anthony most of all, in part, because you never ran out of books because the guy just wrote so damn many. And also because of those long author's notes, which he read as closely as I did.
像我一样，安迪最喜欢皮尔斯·安东尼，部分原因是他的书你永远读不完，因为这家伙写得实在太多了。还因为那些长长的作者随笔，他读得和我一样仔细。
I loved them, and I devoured them as avidly as I did the rest of the book. And all he was describing was like the mundanity of his daily life. But it felt, to me, like he was talking directly to me.
我爱它们，我像读剩下的书一样贪婪地吞噬它们。他描述的一切就像是他日常生活的平凡琐事。但对我来说，感觉就像他在直接对我说话。
And it felt great to have an adult talk to me about the world and talk to me about adult life and leave nothing out, you know? And explain things without it being condescending or talking down to me because I was a kid. And having trouble in school and no friends, it felt like he was a friend.
能有一个成年人跟我谈论世界，跟我谈论成人生活，而且毫无保留，感觉真好，你知道吗？而且他解释事情时没有那种居高临下的优越感，或者因为我是个孩子就看低我。在学校遇到麻烦而且没有朋友，这让我觉得他是个朋友。
Little by little, Andy says he found himself fantasizing less about the wild adventures of Piers Anthony's novels and more about the everyday reality of those notes. And at some point, he stopped sneaking into the magical land of Xanth or the futuristic planet Proton entirely. Instead, he begin to imagine another escape-- what life might be like on the small farm in the modest house he'd read about in those author's notes. To Andy, an ordinary, happy life seemed just as fantasical as the novels themselves.
一点一点地，安迪说他发现自己不再那么幻想皮尔斯·安东尼小说里狂野的冒险，而是更多地幻想那些随笔中日常的现实。在某个时刻，他完全停止溜进Xanth的魔法世界或Proton的未来星球。相反，他开始想象另一种逃离——读那些作者随笔中写的那个小农场、那间朴素的房子里的生活会是什么样。对安迪来说，平凡、幸福的生活看起来和小说本身一样梦幻。
I don't remember exactly when it started, but it kind of crept into my mind. I'd been toying with all kinds of ideas about running away. Like, I imagined myself doing something wild like walking across the entire United States on foot. And a lot of kids want to run away and-- I don't know, what? Live with hobos? I don't know. For me, I wanted an alternate place to live. And so, I imagined walking across the country. And then, somehow I think through these author's notes, I felt like I'd gotten to know this person through these very personal notes. And so I felt like he would be somebody that if I explained my situation, he might care, and that he might give me shelter if I just went there.
我不记得具体是从什么时候开始的，它悄悄进入了我的脑海。我一直想过各种离家出走的想法。比如，我想象自己做些狂野的事，比如徒步横穿整个美国。很多孩子都想离家出走，然后——我不知道，做什么？和流浪汉住在一起？我不知道。对我来说，我想要一个可以替代的地方生活。所以，我想象横跨全国。然后，不知何故，我想通过这些作者随笔，我觉得我通过这些非常个人的随笔认识了这个人。所以我觉得如果我解释我的情况，他可能会关心，如果我去了那里，他可能会给我提供住所。
Right away, Andy faced an enormous obstacle. He didn't actually know where his favorite author lived. But Piers Anthony left hints inside his books. His bestselling series is the Xanth series, a 36-novel universe that takes its name from its location, the magical kingdom of Xanth, a land of wizards and goblins and flirting fairies.
立刻，安迪面临一个巨大的障碍。他其实不知道他最喜欢的作者住在哪儿。但皮尔斯·安东尼在他的书里留下了线索。他最畅销的系列是Xanth系列，一个36部小说的宇宙，得名于它的所在地——Xanth魔法王国，一个巫师、妖精和调情精灵的土地。
I remember looking at maps a lot. I was into maps. I had atlases and stuff like that. And I remember looking at maps a lot and comparing them to the map of Xanth.
我记得我看了很多地图。我对地图很感兴趣。我有地图集之类的东西。我记得我经常看地图并将它们与Xanth的地图进行比较。
As any fan on the books knows, the hand-drawn maps of Xanth look exactly like Florida only Key West become Centaur Aisle, Gainesville becomes a deep, black void, and West Palm Beach is transformed into a literal gold coast where sand castles are sculpted out of golden nuggets.
正如书的任何粉丝都知道的那样，手绘的Xanth地图看起来和佛罗里达一模一样，只是基韦斯特变成了“半人马岛”，盖恩斯维尔变成了一个深邃的黑色虚空，而西棕榈滩变成了真正的黄金海岸，那里用金块雕刻沙堡。
As any fan of the author's notes knows, Piers Anthony lives in Florida. So Andy made a calculated bet-- that the capital of Xanth, that's where he'd find the real Piers Anthony.
正如任何作者随笔的粉丝都知道的那样，皮尔斯·安东尼住在佛罗里达。所以安迪打了一个精算的赌——在Xanth的首都，那就是他会找到真实的皮尔斯·安东尼的地方。
I was a detective. I sort of poured over these books and thought that I'd located, triangulated about exactly where he lived, based on the location of the capital of Xanth, just south of the unicorns. And then, some other offhand comments that he made of stuff that was nearby.
我像个侦探。我研究了这些书，认为我已经定位、三角测量出他准确住在哪里，基于Xanth首都的位置，就在独角兽的南边。然后还有一些他提到的附近事物的随口评论。
And so I had it narrowed down to one of two small towns in rural Florida. It was either Inverness or Floral City.
于是我把它缩小到佛罗里达乡村的两个小镇之一。要么是因弗内斯（Inverness），要么是弗洛勒尔市（Floral City）。
The two towns Andy had zeroed in on, Inverness and Floral City, were about seven miles apart in rural Florida. But Andy decided he could work that out if he got there.
安迪锁定的那两个城镇，因弗内斯和弗洛勒尔市，在佛罗里达乡村相距大约七英里。但安迪决定如果他到了那里，他能解决这个问题。
First, he needed money for a plane ticket. Andy had been working a paper route for years. And his mother had been matching the earnings and depositing them into a college fund that Andy wasn't allowed to touch until after high school. But it seemed like his only shot. So on Thursday, February 19, 1987, Andy walked the half mile to the bank.
首先，他需要钱买机票。安迪做了多年的送报员。他母亲一直匹配他的收入并存入一个大学基金，在高中毕业前安迪不能动用。但这似乎是他唯一的希望。于是1987年2月19日星期四，安迪步行半英里去了银行。
I just went up to the counter. I guess I must have filled out a withdrawal slip. Or maybe not. I think I just had the-- somehow, I got the account number. And I just said, "I want all the money." And I don't know why, but the woman behind the counter-- the account had my name on it. I don't know if I had a student ID or what. But she just said, "OK." And she gave me $1,200 in cash in an envelope. And I was a little astounded by that, that it had worked.
我直接走到柜台前。我想我一定填了一张取款单。或者没有。我想我只是有——不知怎么的，我有账号。我只是说，“我要所有钱。”我不知道为什么，但柜台后的女人——账户上有我的名字。我不知道我是否有学生证还是什么。但她只是说，“好的。”她给了我1200美元现金，装在一个信封里。我对这竟然成功了感到有点震惊。
I think, at this point, I wasn't totally clear on whether any portion of this plan was feasible, right? The whole thing depends on getting money. And then, boom, you've got money. And it almost felt like a dare.
我想，在那一刻，我不完全清楚这个计划的任何一部分是否可行，对吧？整个事情取决于搞到钱。然后，砰，你就有钱了。这感觉几乎像是一个挑战。
With his envelope full of money, Andy prepared to leave the next day. But when he woke up, he chickened out. For three days, he sat on the money and went back and forth about the whole idea. And then finally, on Monday morning, he packed a backpack full of clothes.
拿着装满钱的信封，安迪准备第二天离开。但当他醒来时，他退缩了。三天时间里，他一直带着钱，对整个想法反复纠结。最终，在周一早上，他装了一个塞满衣服的背包。
I kissed my mom goodbye, and I said, "I'm off to school." And instead of going to school, I walked to the airport, which is-- I'd have to look at a map now. But I think it was at least eight miles. And I wasn't totally clear on how to get there. So I think it took me four or five hours to get in that general direction and then figure out where the airport was.
我吻别了妈妈，说，“我去上学了。”然后我没有去学校，而是步行去了机场，这——我现在得看地图才能确定了。但我认为至少有八英里。我不太清楚该怎么去那里。所以我想我花了四五个小时才朝着那个大致方向走去，然后弄清楚机场在哪里。
Andy walked up to the first ticket counter he saw and bought a ticket to Orlando for 300-some dollars. This would be his time on an airplane, his first trip anywhere without his family. He started to worry about his mom. So he bought a postcard with a picture of Niagara Falls on it, and he wrote something about how he had to go away for a while and might visit again in a year, maybe next Christmas. Andy hoped that would be reassuring, so he dropped it in the mail. Then, he got on the plane and hit Play on his Walkman.
安迪走到他看到的第一个售票柜台，买了张票去奥兰多，花了300多美元。这将是他第一次坐飞机，第一次没有家人陪同的旅行。他开始担心妈妈。于是他买了一张上面有尼亚加拉大瀑布照片的明信片，写了一些关于他必须离开一段时间，可能明年、也许是明年圣诞节再回来的话。安迪希望这能让人放心，于是他把它投进了邮箱。然后，他上了飞机，按下了Walkman上的播放键。
What did you imagine was going to happen? What was the goal of all this?
你想象会发生什么？这一切的目标是什么？
I think the goal was to live somewhere else. I think the goal was very simply just what it was. Like, I wanted to go live with Piers Anthony.
我想目标是住在别的地方。我想目标非常简单，就是它本身。就像，我想去和皮尔斯·安东尼一起生活。
Was there a worry at some point, like Piers might not go along with it, or might-- were you certain that you would get there and everything would be cool?
有没有某一刻感到担心，比如皮尔斯可能不会同意，或者可能——你确定到了那里一切都会很酷吗？
Yeah, that's a good question. No, I was not certain. But I think I just, well, I'll worry about that when I get there. Let's see what happens. And I had all kinds of pie in the sky fantasies of what it would be like to live there with him. You know, happy days.
是的，这是一个好问题。不，我不确定。但我想我只是，好吧，我到了那里再说。看看会发生什么。我当时满脑子都是住在那里会是什么样的白日梦。你知道，幸福的日子。
Yeah, what'd you think a day would be like?
是的，你觉得一天会是什么样？
That we would get up, and I could cook breakfast for the family. And then, we would go out into the woods or the fields and ride horses or grow food or do work around the house. I think I wanted that the days would be purposeful for some reason, or that they would be exciting.
我们起床，我可以为家人做早餐。然后，我们去树林或田野骑马、种地或做家务。我想我希望日子是有目的的，或者说它们会很令人兴奋。
Logan, can you correct me if I'm wrong? Does Piers Anthony play the harmonica?
洛根，如果你错了能纠正我吗？皮尔斯·安东尼会吹口琴吗？
Yeah.
是的。
I imagined him teaching me how to play the harmonica.
我幻想他教我吹口琴。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, just like whatever. I imagined myself participating in the daily life that was the Anthony household.
是的，就是那样。我幻想自己参与到安东尼家那样的日常生活中。
Andy touched down late in the afternoon of that Monday, beamed in from the icy cold of Buffalo to the tropical warmth of Florida. He couldn't believe that it had worked. There were no buses to Floral City until the next day, so Andy had to spend the night in Orlando. And actually, the next 24 hours tell you a lot about what Andy was like when he was 15.
安迪在周一的傍晚降落，从布法罗的冰冷寒冬瞬间来到了佛罗里达的热带温暖中。他简直不敢相信竟然成功了。第二天才有去弗洛勒尔市的巴士，所以安迪不得不在奥兰多过夜。实际上，接下来的24小时说明了很多关于安迪15岁时的样子。
He hired a cab, the first cab he'd ever taken. It was driven by a Jamaican guy, the first Jamaican guy he'd ever met. Because he was too young to check into a hotel, Andy paid the cabby $50 to get him a room at the Days Inn.
他雇了一辆出租车，这是他坐过的第一辆车。司机是一个牙买加人，他见过的第一个牙买加人。因为年龄太小不能登记酒店，安迪给了出租车司机50美元，让他帮自己开了个Days Inn的房间。
Then, on the way, Andy thought of the $900 in his pocket. He wondered, "Why not have some fun?" If you can, think of all the things a 15-year-old boy away from home for the first time with no parents might do with nearly $1,000 in cash. Andy turned to the cab driver.
然后，在路上，安迪想到了口袋里的900美元。他想，“为什么不玩得开心点？”如果可以的话，想想一个15岁的男孩第一次离家，没有父母在身边，口袋里有近1000美元现金可能会做什么。安迪转向出租车司机。
So I made him take a little side trip to an art supply store. And I made him keep the cab running. And I went in there, and I was like, wow, I could get anything I wanted. So I got myself a really bad-ass portfolio to keep art in and a bunch of colored pencils, and pens, and paints, and brushes, and whatever else I wanted. I probably spent $180 or something like that, which felt weird. But then, I was like, well why not, right?
所以我让他绕道去了一家美术用品店。我让他别熄火。我走进去，心想，哇，我想要什么都能得到。所以我买了一个非常厉害的艺术作品集，还有一堆彩色铅笔、笔、颜料、刷子，以及任何我想要的东西。我可能花了180美元左右，感觉很奇怪。但后来我想，为什么不呢，对吧？
Right, right.
对，对。
Let the wild rumpus began.
让狂野的混乱开始吧。
Andy spent the night alone in his hotel room drawing until he got hungry. Then, he walked over to a Pizza Hut. Until that point, Andy hadn't been very emotional. He remembers feeling nothing, really, just putting one foot in front of the other executing his great escape. But alone with his personal pan pizza in a restaurant that looked just like the one in Buffalo, he started to think about his mom again.
安迪在酒店房间里独自度过了一晚，一直画画到饿了。然后，他走到必胜客。在那之前，安迪并没有太多的情绪波动。他记得什么都没感觉到，真的，只是执行他伟大的逃离计划，一步接一步地走。但独自坐在餐馆里，吃着和布法罗那家一模一样的个人比萨，他开始想念妈妈了。
He pushed it down, didn't cry. 1,000 miles in, Andy decided he had to see it through. In the morning, he hopped a bus to Floral City and arrived in the town itself. Andy walked into the local drugstore and asked for the telephone book. He had based this entire journey on a hunch that Piers Anthony lived in the capitol of Xanth. Now, looking in the phone book under A, there was no listing for Piers Anthony.
他把这种情绪压下去，没哭。已经走了1000英里，安迪决定一定要坚持到底。第二天早上，他跳上一辆去弗洛勒尔市的巴士，到达了那个镇上。安迪走进当地的药店，要了电话簿。他这次整个旅程都是基于一个猜测：皮尔斯·安东尼住在Xanth的首都。现在，在电话簿里查A项，没有皮尔斯·安东尼的条目。
But he didn't panic. Andy knew that Piers Anthony's full name was really Piers Anthony Dillingham Jacob. He searched through the phone book and found a listing for Jacob, comma, P. Beside it, there was an address.
但他没有惊慌。安迪知道皮尔斯·安东尼的全名其实是皮尔斯·安东尼·迪林厄姆·雅各布（Piers Anthony Dillingham Jacob）。他在电话簿里搜寻，找到了一个“雅各布，P”的条目。旁边有一个地址。
Next, Andy hitched a ride. And the very first car to come along, a red Cadillac, stopped. He told the nice guy who picked him up a story about how he's visiting his uncle, and then ended up having to keep this lie going for several hours because after looking and looking for Piers Anthony's address, they realized the name of the street had been changed. They asked around and drove some more and eventually ended up on a long road into the woods.
接下来，安迪搭了便车。第一辆经过的车，一辆红色凯迪拉克，停了下来。他告诉那个好心的搭车人一个故事，说他在拜访叔叔，然后不得不保持这个谎言好几个小时，因为在到处寻找皮尔斯·安东尼的地址后，他们意识到街道名称变了。他们到处问人，又开了更多的车，最终进入了一条通往树林的漫长道路。
At this point, we had been driving for at least three hours. It's getting more and more wooded. You're basically driving into the woods. And the road stops being paved. And then, there's wooden fence posts. But it's not clear what the wooden fence is holding in or keeping out because there's just trees everywhere.
此时，我们已经开了至少三个小时了。树木越来越多。你基本上是在往树林里开。路不再是柏油路了。然后，有木栅栏柱。但不清楚木栅栏在围住什么或挡住什么，因为到处都是树。
And then, we get to the address. And in my mind, it's at the end of a dead end. But I don't think it was. I think it just took forever, so it seemed like it was the end of a dead end. And we get there. And I'm like, "OK, thanks a lot." I don't really want this guy to find out that it wasn't my uncle and that I don't actually know this person. So I just jump out the car. I grab my book bag. I'm like, "Later days, thank you."
然后，我们到了那个地址。在我的印象里，它在一条死胡同的尽头。但我不觉得是。我想只是开了太久，所以看起来像是在死胡同尽头。我们到了那里。我说，“好的，太感谢了。”我真的不想让这家伙发现那不是我叔叔，我其实不认识这个人。所以我直接跳下车。我抓起书包。我说，“再见了，谢谢。”
And then, just then, I knew that Piers Anthony had dogs. But I didn't expect them to be insane, big, mean dogs, which is what they turned out to be. At least, in my memory they are. And there's a house. And then, there's a little shack out back which I immediately gathered was Piers' writing shack.
然后，就在这时，我知道皮尔斯·安东尼有狗。但我没料到它们会是疯的、大的、凶狠的狗，事实证明它们确实如此。至少，在我的记忆里它们是。而且有一栋房子。然后，后面有一个小棚屋，我立刻猜到那是皮尔斯的写作棚。
Which he wrote about, yeah.
他确实写过，是的。
Yeah. And so the ruckus draws his attention. And this bearded head pops out and sees me standing at the gate and comes out. And I was like, "Oh my god, it's the man. This is my idol here." And he just comes up to the gate. And he's like, "Can I help you?"
是的。骚动引起了他的注意。那个留胡子的头探出来，看到我站在门口，走了出来。我说，“天哪，是那个人。我的偶像就在这儿。”他走到门口。他说，“我能帮你吗？”
And at that point, I've been through so much. And I didn't really-- when he said, "Can I help you," or "What can I do for you," I didn't even know what to say. How do you explain, "What are you doing here?" And I just burst into tears and starting saying, begging him, "Can I stay with you? I can cook. I could help you do blah, blah, blah. Please, help me."
在那一刻，我已经经历了太多。我真的——当他说，“我能帮你吗，”或者“我能为你做什么，”我甚至不知道说什么。你怎么解释，“你在这儿干什么？”我只是泪如雨下，开始说，求他，“我能和你住在一起吗？我会做饭。我可以帮你做这个那个。求你，帮帮我。”
And I could tell he was just totally taken aback. And he just kind of shook his head and was like, "Ah, you should-- you better come inside. We need to talk about this." And I was like, "OK." And that seemed like progress. I was invited into the house. So we went in the house. We went in. And he sat down with me and proceeded to listen to my story and listen to my tale of woe of high school misery.
我看得出他完全被惊到了。他只是摇了摇头说，“啊，你最好——你还是进来吧。我们需要谈谈这个。”我说，“好的。”这看起来像是进展。我被邀请进屋了。于是我们进屋了。我们进去。他坐下来，开始听我的故事，听我关于高中苦难的哀诉。
Andy says he told Piers Anthony everything. He talked and talked. He remembers that Piers Anthony said very little. Mostly, he just listened as Andy laid out all the reasons why he was there that day. He told Piers about school, about how he had no friends, and about his home life and his stepfather, about how alone he felt. Andy doesn't know exactly how long they sat there talking, but he knows it was hours.
安迪说他告诉了皮尔斯·安东尼一切。他滔滔不绝地讲。他记得皮尔斯·安东尼说得很少。大部分时间，他只是听，听安迪陈述那天他为什么会在那里。他告诉皮尔斯关于学校的事，关于他没有朋友的事，关于他的家庭生活和继父的事，关于他感到多么孤独的事。安迪不知道他们坐着聊了多久，但他知道那是几个小时。
And so we sat there. And he listened to my story. And we got to the end of it, and I was like, "So, can I stay with you?" And he was just like, "Ah, no. First of all, my wife would kill me if I took in a runaway." And we didn't really get to any more reasons than that, you know?
我们就坐在那儿。他听我的故事。聊到最后，我说，“那，我可以和你住在一起吗？”他只是说，“啊，不行。首先，如果我收留一个离家出走的人，我妻子会杀了我。”我们没有深入讨论更多的理由了，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
I'm sure that he was trying to let me down as easy as he could and be as-- which I guess involves passing the buck. "Hey, it's not me, man." It's a typical parent thing. "It wasn't me. It's your mom."
我敢肯定他是在尽量温和地拒绝我——我猜这涉及到推卸责任。“嘿，不是我，伙计。”这是一个典型的家长式做法。“不是我。是你妈的问题。”
But when he said that, it made sense to me. I was like, "Ah, yeah. What I'm doing is wacky." I think it hit me for the first time. Like, this is a really strange situation. And this is a lot that I'm asking this person.
但当他说那话时，我觉得有道理。我想，“啊，是的。我做的事很荒唐。”我想这是我第一次意识到。就像，这真是个奇怪的情况。而且我向这个人要求太多了。
And then he said, "Look, I know that things are bad. But at this point, you have a couple options. If you think things are so bad that you don't want to go back home, I can help put you in touch with people that will help runaways. Or if you think that things aren't that bad, you should call your parents and go back." Both of which seemed like really sensible options. And so when he said that to me, I realized, OK, I need to go back.
然后他说，“听着，我知道情况很糟。但现在，你有几个选择。如果你认为情况糟到你不想回家，我可以帮你联系那些帮助离家出走者的机构。或者如果你认为情况没那么糟，你应该给父母打电话回去。”这两个听起来都像是非常合理的选择。所以当他那样对我讲时，我意识到，好的，我需要回去。
Did you feel-- so it sounds like you didn't feel disappointed that he was essentially saying, no this fantasy you had of moving in with me is not going to happen.
你觉得——所以听起来你并没有感到失望，因为他基本上是在说，不，你幻想和我一起生活是不会发生的。
Right. No, I think I might have felt a moment of disappointment when he first said no. But I think after-- the fact that he didn't just dismiss it out of hand as soon as I got there, that he sat down and listened to me and talked with me and tried to advise me in a really caring way, and me outlining my situation in words made me stop and really think about my situation more clearly, too. I think it made complete sense that he would say no. It didn't seem like a cruel thing to say.
对。不，我想我在他第一次拒绝时可能有一瞬间的失望。但我认为之后——他并没有在我一到那里就草率地打发我，而是坐下来听我倾诉，和我交流，并以非常关心的方式建议我，让我把自己的情况诉说出来，这让我停下来，也更清楚地思考了自己的处境。我觉得他拒绝是完全有道理的。这听起来不像是一件残忍的事情。
I felt a little disappointment that my fantasy had smacked into an uncooperative reality. But I felt sort of invigorated about reality itself from that and more interested in working with reality rather than retreating into fantasy. Which is ironic that that's what a fantasy author-- that my interaction with a fantasy author was not more fantasy, that my interaction with a fantasy author was plain reality. And it just felt good to be heard and to be accepted.
我感到一点点失望，因为我的幻想撞上了一个不配合的现实。但我从中感到了一种对现实本身的振奋，并对面对现实而非逃避进幻想中更感兴趣。这很讽刺，作为一个奇幻作家——我与奇幻作家的互动居然没有更多奇幻内容，我与奇幻作家的互动居然是平庸的现实。被倾听和被接纳感觉真好。
Andy says that was the first time anyone had listened to him explain why he was so unhappy. And it felt like a fever or hex had broken. Afterwards, Piers Anthony called Andy's mother. And Andy remembers the sound of relief in her voice. They made plans to drive Andy to the airport the next day.
安迪说那是第一次有人倾听他解释为什么自己如此不快乐。感觉就像一场高烧或诅咒被打破了。之后，皮尔斯·安东尼给安迪的母亲打了电话。安迪记得她声音里的宽慰。他们计划第二天开车送安迪去机场。
But first, Andy would spend the night in Piers Anthony's house. He'd get his wish for one day. That afternoon, Andy walked around Anthony's farm with Piers Anthony's teenage daughter. He saw the horse named Blue who became the unicorn in Xanth and the gnarled branches that twisted their way into the horror novel, The Shade of the Tree .
但首先，安迪会在皮尔斯·安东尼家里过夜。他如愿以偿了一天。那天下午，安迪陪着皮尔斯·安东尼十几岁的女儿在农场四处走动。他看到了那匹名叫“蓝色”的马，它成了Xanth里的独角兽，还看到了那些扭曲进恐怖小说《树荫下》的扭曲树枝。
And though he didn't cook dinner for them as he'd imagined, he ate at the table with a family he'd hoped would replace his own. After dinner, Andy sat on the couch with the Anthonys and watched a bad cop show on TV. And he remembers that feeling good and normal.
虽然他没像幻想中那样为他们做晚餐，但他和那个他希望取代自己家人的家庭坐在一起吃饭。晚餐后，安迪和安东尼一家坐在沙发上看了电视上的烂警匪片。他记得那种感觉很好，很正常。
After the show, Piers Anthony gave Andy a copy of his latest manuscript and set up a bed for him in the room of their older daughter who was away at college. Andy lay in bed reading about a young, Indian prince who gets recruited to become the god of war. With the world on the brink of apocalypse, the prince is the only one who can save it by learning how to turn back the hands of a doomsday clock. Comforted, Andy fell asleep, book on his chest.
节目结束后，皮尔斯·安东尼给了安迪他最新书稿的复印件，并在他们的大女儿——在外地上大学——的房间里为安迪铺好了床。安迪躺在床上，读着一个年轻的印度王子被招募成为战神的故事。世界处于末日边缘，王子是唯一能通过学习如何拨回末日时钟来拯救世界的人。感到安慰，安迪睡着了，书放在胸口。
Andy returned to mundania the next day. His family picked him up at the airport in Buffalo, relieved that he was back. Andy embarked on a crazy quest and actually pulled it off. He studied cryptic maps and pieced together clues, faced down dogs at the gate, and fought his way to the oracle. In a fantasy novel, when a quest is completed, everything changes in an instant. The zombies turn to ash. The aliens disappear into the mother ship.
安迪第二天回到了现实世界。他的家人在布法罗机场接到了他，因为他回来而感到宽慰。安迪开始了一项疯狂的探险，竟然成功了。他研究了神秘的地图，拼凑出线索，面对门口的恶犬，一路拼搏找到了神谕。在奇幻小说里，任务完成后，一切瞬间改变。僵尸化为灰烬。外星人消失在母舰里。
But Andy was right back where he started. He still hated school. He still struggled to make friends. He still flunked every class. In fact, he'd have to repeat the 10th grade all over again like some accursed time traveler.
但安迪回到了他开始的地方。他依然讨厌学校。他依然很难交到朋友。他依然挂掉所有的课。事实上，他不得不像个被诅咒的时间旅行者一样重读十年级。
If anything, his relationship with his stepfather actually got worse. Even so, something was different. Something had shifted. After Florida, Andy felt for the first time like there was a better world out there somewhere and he could find it.
如果有的话，他和继父的关系实际上变得更糟了。尽管如此，有些东西不同了。有些东西发生了转变。从佛罗里达回来后，安迪第一次觉得外面有一个更好的世界，他可以找到它。
And the whole thing was like fresh air. It was like I pulled the lid off what had formerly seemed like this trapped existence where every situation was unpleasant and there didn't seem to be any way out. And so I just forced a way out like a hero in one of Piers Anthony's novels.
这一切就像清新的空气。就像我掀开了那个曾经看起来像这种被困的存在，那种情况每一刻都很不愉快，而且看起来毫无出路的盖子。所以我只是像皮尔斯·安东尼小说里的英雄一样强行开辟了一条出路。
And it was completely refreshing. Yeah, it wasn't what I thought it would be or what I wanted it to be. But it was exactly what I needed it to be. It was great.
这简直令人耳目一新。是的，它不是我想象或想要的样子。但它正是当时我所需要的。棒极了。
OK, so we're dialing Piers Anthony. I kind of have butterflies.
好的，我们要给皮尔斯·安东尼打电话了。我有点紧张。
This is surreal.
这太超现实了。
In the 25 years since Andy's adventure, he often thought of getting back in touch with Piers Anthony if only to thank him, to let him know that he turned out OK. But he never got around to it. So we set up a call.
在安迪冒险过去的25年里，他经常想重新联系皮尔斯·安东尼，哪怕只是为了感谢他，让他知道自己过得不错。但他一直没腾出时间。所以我们安排了一次通话。
[PHONE RINGS]
[电话铃声]
Hello?
你好？
Andy was worried that Piers Anthony might not even remember him. But he did.
安迪很担心皮尔斯·安东尼可能根本不记得他了。但他记得。
One of the things I do, I keep a record each day of what I do. Usually, it's just how much I write and how much I read and so on. And one of those days, I'd had, "Andy, four hours."
我做的事情之一，就是每天记录我做的事。通常只是我写了多少、读了多少之类的。在其中一天，我记录了，“安迪，四个小时。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Actually, Piers Anthony remembered nearly everything.
其实，皮尔斯·安东尼几乎记得一切。
Well, you told me how your stepfather was basically mean to you. And you didn't like it. As far as I know, your mother was OK. But as far as I know, she didn't oppose your stepfather. And so it made it ugly for you. And that, I understood without needing to understand the details.
好吧，你告诉我你的继父基本上对你很刻薄。你不喜欢那样。据我所知，你母亲还算好。但据我所知，她没有反对你的继父。所以这对你来说很痛苦。这一点，我不需要细节也能理解。
Yeah. Your memory's very clear.
是的。你的记忆很清晰。
But I do remember my general advice as such was keep your head down. Endure it. In a few years, you can get out.
但我记得我当时给你的总建议是低调行事。忍受它。几年后，你就能离开。
Uh-huh, yes.
嗯嗯，是的。
And I think that's what you must have done.
我想你一定是那么做的。
Yes, absolutely. I think that's part of what made the next few years more bearable.
是的，绝对。我想这也是让接下来几年变得更容易忍受的部分原因。
They talked for an hour. Andy thanked Piers Anthony for his kindness that day. And what became clear to me as I listened to them was that Piers Anthony had seen a lot of himself in the 15-year-old Andy. He said he'd had a rough childhood of his own-- divorced parents, bed wetting, bullies at school, lousy grades, all of it.
他们聊了一个小时。安迪感谢皮尔斯·安东尼当年的善意。当我在听他们谈话时，很明显，皮尔斯·安东尼在15岁的安迪身上看到了很多自己的影子。他说他自己也有过一段艰难的童年——父母离异、尿床、学校里的恶霸、烂成绩，这一切。
My high school was a very fancy private school and so on. They constantly solicit me for money to contribute to it. I never do. Because there, I was one of the-- they had the upper crust, and they had the lower crust. I was the lower crust. I was the one that nobody paid any attention to, that nobody cared about. I didn't like being a member of the underclass of the peons like that.
我的高中是一所非常高级的私立学校之类的。他们不断向我要钱捐赠给学校。我从来不给。因为在那里，我是……他们有上层社会，也有下层社会。我是下层社会。我是那个没人注意、没人关心的人。我不喜欢当那样处于底层的无名小卒。
No one does.
没人喜欢。
When I was in high school, I was in study hall and caught up on my homework. And I was reading a fantasy magazine. And a proctor came by, caught it, threw it away. Well, you want to know one reason I don't contribute to that school? That is one reason out of many.
我在读高中时，在自习课写作业。我当时在看一本奇幻杂志。一个监考员走过来，抓住了，把它扔掉了。嗯，你想知道我为什么不向那所学校捐款的一个原因吗？这就是原因之一，多的是原因中的一个。
Uh-huh.
嗯嗯。
People talk-- they sneer at escapism. Well, there are those of us who need it.
人们谈论……他们蔑视逃避主义。嗯，我们这些人需要它。
Piers Anthony is 77 years old now. But really, he was just an angry kid who'd muddled through like everyone else, which surprised Andy. In the author's notes from his book Fractal Mode , book two of his Mode series, he writes, "One thing you who had secure or happy childhoods should understand about those of us who did not, we who control our feelings, who avoid conflicts at all costs or seem to seek them, who are hypersensitive, self-critical, compulsive, workaholic, and above all survivors, we're not that way from perversity. And we cannot just relax and let it go. We've learned to cope in ways you never had to."
皮尔斯·安东尼现在77岁了。但实际上，他只是一个像其他人一样艰难挺过来的愤怒孩子，这让安迪很惊讶。在他的书《分形模式》（Fractal Mode，模式系列的第二本）的作者随笔中，他写道，“你们这些拥有安全或幸福童年的人应该理解我们这些没有的人，我们这些控制自己情感的人，那些不惜一切代价避免冲突或者似乎在寻求冲突的人，那些高度敏感、自我批评、强迫症、工作狂，最重要的是生存者，我们变成这样不是因为变态。而且我们不能只是放松并放下。我们学会了以你们从未有过的方式来应对。”
Logan Hill. He's a senior editor at GQ magazine.
洛根·希尔。《GQ》杂志的高级编辑。
Coming up, no grime, mimes, or chimes, no organized crime, no vines to climb, just rhymes in one minute's time from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，没有污垢，没有默剧，没有叮当，没有有组织犯罪，没有藤蔓可爬，只有一分钟的韵律，来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际，我们的节目即将继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Show Me the Way, stories of what happens when you turn to unusual people or maybe even the wrong person for advice. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Oh, the Places You Won't Go.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目，《指引我方向》，讲述当你向不寻常的人甚至可能是错误的人寻求建议时会发生什么的故事。我们现在进行到节目的第二幕。第二幕，哦，你不会去的地方。
In this act, like in the first act, somebody needs help. And instead of turning to those nearby, he writes a letter. The correspondence is read by Jonathan Goldstein and David Rakoff.
在这一幕中，像第一幕一样，有人需要帮助。他没有求助附近的人，而是写了一封信。通信由乔纳森·戈德斯坦（Jonathan Goldstein）和大卫·拉科夫（David Rakoff）朗读。
Herr doctor, I find myself, for reasons inexplicable to me or my loving family, to have woken up this morning transformed into a cockroach. I am reasonably certain this is not a dream. Can you help?
赫尔医生，我发现由于某种无法向我和我亲爱的家人解释的原因，今天早晨醒来时变成了一只蟑螂。我相当确定这不是梦。你能帮忙吗？
I am usually in very fine fettle in the morning. But as a result of my new condition, I find myself unable to go into work. And while my life has never been what you might call a bed of roses, this unfortunate turn of events has certainly made it worse.
通常早晨我总是精神焕发。但因为我的新状况，我发现自己无法去上班了。虽然我的生活从来称不上舒适安逸，但这次不幸的转折肯定让它变得更糟了。
By way of example, this letter has been composed by painstakingly mashing my antenna into the keys of my father's typewriter. It has taken me close to four hours and has left me with a horrendous migraine. I write to you because I have heard of your brilliance and your keen appreciation for the absurdity of this world. Please help. Yours, Gregor Samsa, Prague.
举个例子，这封信是我费尽心机用触角敲打父亲打字机的按键写成的。它花了我快四个小时，让我偏头痛发作。我写信给你是因为我听说过你的才华以及你对这个世界荒谬性的敏锐洞察力。请帮帮我。你的，格里高尔·萨姆沙（Gregor Samsa），布拉格。
Samsa, I've only just opened your letter. Fear not, worry neither. We'll soon have you better. You might feel like a freak, but I'll make you quite well. Your problem's unique, yet your name rings a bell. A silkworm I knew used to live in a trillium. I think his name was Samsa. Or was it Fitzwilliam?
萨姆沙，我刚拆开你的信。莫怕，莫愁。很快你就会好起来。你可能感觉自己像个怪物，但我会让你完全好转。你的问题很独特，但你的名字听起来很耳熟。我认识的一只蚕曾住在一株延龄草里。我想他叫萨姆沙。还是菲茨威廉？
Oh, well. Please forgive me. My mind is a haze. One really meets so many faces nowadays.
哦，好吧。请原谅。我的大脑一片混沌。现在真的会见到太多面孔。
If you ooze like a slug or you prick like a cactus, every ill-feeling bug finds his way to my practice. Whether dozens of styes mar your 100-eyed face, whatever your ailment, you're in the right place. Not to brag, but I've never yet failed to determine whatever root causes were vexing a vermin.
如果你像鼻涕虫一样流淌，或者像仙人掌一样刺人，每一只感觉不适的虫子都会找到我的诊所。无论几十个麦粒肿遮住了你那一百只眼睛的脸，不管你有什么病，你都找对地方了。不是自夸，但我从未失败过，总能找出困扰害虫的根源。
Rest assured, I'll endeavor to glean and deduce. You'll be better than ever or my name isn't Seuss.
放心吧，我会努力推断并演绎。你会比以往任何时候都好，否则我就不叫苏斯（Seuss）。
Dear Dr. Seuss, perhaps you do not understand. And for this, I am probably to blame for not having made this point more clear. While I am now a cockroach, I was not always one. I was born a man and am now a bug.
亲爱的苏斯医生，也许你不明白。这很可能是我的错，因为没把这一点说清楚。虽然我现在是一只蟑螂，但我并不总是这样。我生而为人，现在却是一只虫子。
Do you see? Is this even pertinent to my case? I mention it only in the interest of aiding your diagnosis. I hope I have not offended you with my quibbling. If I have, the only defense I can offer is that I have not been myself.
你明白了吗？这对我的案例有关系吗？我提到这一点只是为了辅助你的诊断。希望我没用这些琐事冒犯你。如果有的话，我能提供的唯一辩护就是我一直都不在状态。
I feel that time is of the essence in this matter because without my being able to go into the office, I fear my whole family will all too soon wind up in the poor house. To migrate embarrassment, my father has already taken to eating his meals with lesser employees of the bank. Very sincerely, Gregor Samsa.
我觉得在这件事上时间至关重要，因为如果我不能去办公室上班，我担心我们全家很快就会陷入赤贫。为了掩饰尴尬，我父亲已经开始和银行里地位较低的员工一起用餐了。诚挚地，格里高尔·萨姆沙。
PS, pardon me if this is a rude question, but I must ask. Is metrical rhyme an American mode of correspondence? If so, I apologize for not responding in kind. Were circumstances different-- that is, were I not a bug-- I would have very much enjoyed the challenge. As it is, though, typing even the simplest of prose taxes me for hours.
附：如果这是一个粗鲁的问题，请原谅，但我必须问。押韵是否是一种美国的通信模式？如果是这样，我为没用同样的方式回复而道歉。如果情况不同——也就是说，如果我不是一只虫子——我会非常享受这个挑战。正如现在这样，敲出最简单的散文都要花掉我几个小时。
The way that I speak gets a comment each time. Some people have accents, while I like to rhyme. Just as those who I treat might have thorax or a stinger, but nothing that ever resembled a finger, it's simply my way. I mean nothing by it. If you'd digits to type with, I'd tell you to try it.
我说话的方式每次都会引发评论。有些人有口音，而我喜欢押韵。就像我治疗的人可能长着胸腔或毒针，但没有长得像手指的东西一样，这只是我的方式。我并没有别的意思。如果你有手指可以用来打字，我会让你试一试的。
But still, this attempt to be merely convivial can backfire sometimes and make me seem trivial. And then, I am forced to make mollifications by dryly reciting my qualifications.
但依然，这种试图保持友好的尝试有时会事与愿违，让我显得微不足道。然后，我就被迫通过枯燥地背诵我的资格来安抚大家。
See, I'm a doctor who chiefly helps insects particular, a recap just briefly of my vitae curricular. One patient of mine, a tubercular chigger, was referred by a june bug who'd shrunk, then got bigger. I made the arrangements and booked him a trip to a mulberry thicket for that flea with the grip.
看，我是医生，主要帮助特定的昆虫，简要回顾一下我的履历。我的一个病人，一个肺结核红螨，是一个缩小后又变大的金龟子推荐来的。我做了安排，并为那只抓力强的跳蚤预订了去桑葚丛的旅行。
And there did he rest and sip syllabub tea. But the thicket's the ticket for curing a flea. A potato bug who would eat nothing but onions, a millipede suffering from 2,000 bunions. A night crawler who could crawl only by day, a mantis who lost the volition to pray. A fruit fly whose flying resisted fruition are just a short list of the kinds of conditions I've treated. And all were made well double-quick. I'm the one who they call when a crawly is sick.
他在那里休息并啜饮甜奶茶。但灌木丛才是治疗跳蚤的良药。一个只吃洋葱的薯虫，一个饱受两千个鸡眼痛苦的千足虫。一个只能白天爬行的蚯蚓，一个失去了祈祷意愿的螳螂。一个飞行受到阻碍的果蝇，这只是我治疗过的病情的一小部分名单。而且所有人都很快痊愈了。当爬虫生病时，他们找的就是我。
But cockroach to human, or vice or verse? What a mystery, a new one confounding. What's worse is I've leafed through the pages of yellowing journals. Through thoughts from the sages I've sifted for kernels. And no one, it seems, has devised an approach for how to return to a man from a roach. For the nonce, I'd advise some geranium juice. But stop if it turns your extremities puce. And I will consult with my college chum Bruce. Till then, stay strong, Samsa. Your loyal friend, Seuss.
但蟑螂变人，或反之亦然？这真是一个困扰人的新谜题。更糟的是，我翻遍了泛黄期刊的页面。我从智者的思想中筛选出内核。似乎没有人制定过如何从蟑螂变回人的方法。暂时来说，我建议喝点天竺葵汁。但如果它让你的四肢变成深紫色，就停下来。我会和我的大学同学布鲁斯（Bruce）商量一下。在那之前，坚强点，萨姆沙。你忠诚的朋友，苏斯。
Dear Doctor, please forgive me for my presumption. But I fear you may not appreciate the gravity of my situation. I am a hideous monster, and I'm only getting worse. Earlier today, my own father lobbed a basket of apples at me, one of which is still embedded in the soft flesh of my back. Our charwoman, too, has grown weary of my grotesque, physical appearance.
亲爱的医生，请原谅我的冒昧。但我担心你可能没体会到我处境的严重性。我是一个丑陋的怪物，而且情况只会变得更糟。今天早些时候，我父亲向我投掷了一篮苹果，其中一个现在还嵌在我背部柔软的肉里。我们的女工也厌倦了我那怪诞的身体外表。
And whereas once she entered my room with good-natured shouts of, "Come out, you old cockroach!" when I hid beneath the couch, now she threatens to crack me on the crown with a chair when I crawl too close. At your word, I am prepared to have my dear sister, the only one who seems to be able to stomach me, pack me into a wooden crate with air holes and ship me to your office.
以前她曾带着善意的呼喊走进我的房间说，“出来吧，你这只老蟑螂！”当我躲在沙发下时，现在当我爬得太近时，她威胁要用椅子砸我的头。只要你一句话，我就准备让我亲爱的妹妹——唯一似乎能忍受我的人，把我装进一个有通气孔的木箱子里，寄到你的诊所。
My fate rests in your hands. Please, doctor, you are my only hope. Yours, G Samsa.
我的命运掌握在你手中。请，医生，你是我唯一的希望。你的，G·萨姆沙。
Oh, Samsa, descriptions like that are invidious. It's human and callous to call yourself hideous. I reckon among those of similar breed, you're actually handsome, quite handsome indeed.
哦，萨姆沙，那种描述令人反感。称自己丑陋既没人情味又冷酷。我估计在同类中，你其实很帅，确实非常帅。
Remember when tempted to heap self-reproach that he who formed lilies created the roach. But now to this new factor with which I must grapple. You say you've been wounded, that now there's an apple that's currently making its home in your back. Is it in the soft tissue? Did your carapace crack?
在想自我谴责时，请记住，塑造百合花的那位也创造了蟑螂。但现在回到我必须处理的这个新因素。你说你受伤了，现在有一个苹果正安家在你的背上。它是在软组织里吗？你的壳裂了吗？
I've questioned my colleagues and asked my attorney about your perhaps maybe making the journey to see me and thereby see your problems ended. Alas, the consensus is not recommend.
我询问了我的同事并咨询了我的律师，关于你也许可能进行前往我这里看病的旅程，从而让你的问题得以终结。唉，共识是不推荐。
The trip is too long, and they would not allow a cockroach through customs. Plus, I don't see how it would any way help ease your suffering and pain. The cost of the postage alone is insane.
路程太长，他们不会允许蟑螂过海关的。再说，我不觉得这对减轻你的痛苦和折磨有任何帮助。光是邮费就贵得惊人。
But do not lose hope. Disregard the above. I have news. I've engaged the services of a carrier jubjub bird flying to you and in his beak berries, one green and one blue. Chew the blue 30 times, and the green 30, too. In a week's time, you'll see that you'll be good as new.
但不要失去希望。忽略上面的话。我有消息。我雇了一只正在飞往你那里的送信Jubjub鸟，它的喙里叼着浆果，一颗绿色，一颗蓝色。把蓝色嚼30次，绿色也嚼30次。一周后，你会发现自己会焕然一新。
Now, rest and eat lots of magnolia custard and rosehip souffle and some dew drops with mustard. And pay special mind if you're starting to blister. Wash the area daily. You mentioned a sister? Is she the one there who might broker a truce? Samsa, please take good care. Concernedly, Seuss.
现在，休息并多吃玉兰蛋奶冻、玫瑰果舒芙蕾和带芥末的露水。如果开始起泡，请特别留意。每天洗洗伤口。你提到有一个妹妹？是她可以从中斡旋达成停火吗？萨姆沙，请好好照顾自己。关切地，苏斯。
Dear doctor, I feared at the beginning of this ordeal that I was no longer me. And now, I know this certainly to be the case. At first, I thought my change had to do merely with the physical, with this horrifying metamorphosis. But now, I see that it is much deeper than that.
亲爱的医生，在这次磨难的开始，我害怕我不再是我自己了。现在，我知道事实确实如此。起初，我以为我的改变仅仅与身体有关，与这种恐怖的变形有关。但现在，我看到它深得多。
I used to wonder in my idle moments in a train carriage or an unfamiliar hotel bedroom when I was still traveling for my work, what might I do if ever my scant good fortune ran out? "Well, Gregor," I used to think to myself, "that would be easy. If I ever became a burden to the family, I would simply walk out the front door and throw myself in front of a team of carriage horses."
当我还因为工作旅行时，我曾好奇地在火车车厢或不熟悉的旅馆卧室里徘徊，如果我仅有的微薄运气耗尽了，我会怎么办？“好吧，格里高尔，”我曾对自己想，“那很简单。如果我成了家人的负担，我就直接走出门，把自己扔进马车队前。”
You have told me to stay strong, not to give up, as if the two were opposite things. But I'm afraid you are mistaken. We both are. Sometimes, to give oneself up one must be strong.
你告诉我保持坚强，不要放弃，好像这两者是相反的事情。但我担心你弄错了。我们都错了。有时，为了放弃自己，一个人必须坚强。
In thanks for your friendship, I have composed for you a rhyme. It's the first one I've written since my boyhood. And you'll have to pardon me if it isn't very good.
为了感谢你的友谊，我为你写了一首韵文。这是我儿时以来的第一首。如果写得不好，请原谅。
You shall be remembered as the doctor who tried to determine what turned Gregor Samsa to vermin. Forgive me. I was not able to get any further. Goodbye, dear Dr. Seuss. Samsa, I am-sa.
你将被铭记为试图确定是什么让格里高尔·萨姆沙变成害虫的医生。原谅我。我无法再继续写下去了。再见，亲爱的苏斯医生。萨姆沙，我即是萨姆沙。
I read your last letter with no small alarm. It sounds like you're fixing to do yourself harm. I know that you feel like you've got nothing left, like your time has run out, you're abandoned, bereft of all hope, that you've been forced to bear it in silence, your family's scorn, their indifference, their violence.
我读着你最后的信，内心充满警惕。听起来你打算伤害自己。我知道你觉得已一无所有，觉得时间耗尽，感到被抛弃、被剥夺了一切希望，觉得必须在沉默中忍受这一切，忍受家人的蔑视、冷漠和暴力。
I take it the jubjub bird failed to arrive. So how, my dear friend, will we keep you alive? I'd recommend exercise, plenty of fruit, but finally cede that such bromides are moot. Samsa, I need you to martial your will. There isn't a purgative, poultice or pill or anything else on the pharmacy shelf that will make you so healthy as much as yourself.
我想Jubjub鸟没能到达。那么，我亲爱的朋友，我们该如何让你活下去？我建议运动，多吃水果，但最终承认这些陈词滥调毫无意义。萨姆沙，我需要你振作起来。药店的货架上没有什么泻药、膏药或药片，或任何其他东西，能让你像你自己那样健康。
You think your new body has made you a bother. You hold yourself guilty while blameless your father. Gregor, we'd all die if physical beauty was needed for others to render their duty.
你认为你的新身体让你成了累赘。你认为自己有罪，而你的父亲无辜。格里高尔，如果外在的美貌是他人履行职责的必要条件，我们都会死。
Ever since our first letter, I've had this strange notion that I'd make you better, ignoring the ocean that makes up the distance that renders you Seussless. But despite my persistence, I've been worse than useless. I'm astonished at times when I think of the past, of my thousands of rhymes, of how life is so vast. I'm left, then, to wonder how anyone gleans a purpose or sense of what anything means.
自从我们第一封信以来，我一直有一种奇怪的想法，想让你好起来，忽视了构成距离让你远离苏斯（Seussless）的海洋。但尽管我坚持，我却比没用还要糟糕。当我想起过去，想起我的数千首韵文，想起生命如此广阔时，我时常感到惊讶。我只能怀疑，任何人如何能从中理出任何意义或目的。
It's not ours for the knowing. It's meaning abstruse. We both best be going. Your loving friend, Seuss.
我们无法获知。意义深奥难懂。我们最好都上路了。你挚爱的朋友，苏斯。
Dear doctor, I found your letters among my brother's things when my parents and I were cleaning out our flat in preparation of moving. It is my sad duty to inform you that Gregor died some three weeks ago, perhaps from his injury, an act for which my father blamed himself for days on end, although I doubt it.
亲爱的医生，当我的父母和我为准备搬家清理公寓时，我在我哥哥的东西里发现了你的信。我有令人悲伤的义务通知你，格里高尔大约在三周前去世了，也许是因为他的伤，我父亲为此责怪自己多日，虽然我对此表示怀疑。
I think Gregor may well have starved himself to death. When the charwoman found him, she pushed at his body with the handle of her broom, and he slid across the floor with no more weight than a dried leaf. Before our charwoman disposed of him, I took one last look and saw that Gregor's shell had cracked open. And just underneath were little wings. He was a beetle, not a cockroach as we had feared. A beetle, nothing more. Even the word is lovely.
我想格里高尔很可能是饿死的。当女工发现他时，她用扫帚柄推了推他的身体，他滑过地板，重量竟如枯叶。在女工处理掉他之前，我最后看了一眼，发现格里高尔的外壳裂开了。下面露出了一对小翅膀。他是一只甲虫，不是我们所害怕的蟑螂。一只甲虫，仅此而已。甚至连这个词都很美。
I know that ever since his childhood, Gregor had always had very vivid dreams of flight that left him happy in the morning. If only he himself had known, I kept thinking. At any rate, dear doctor, I thought you should know what befell my poor brother and to thank you for all your efforts in his behalf. If you should find yourself ever in Prague, please consider yourself most welcome in our home. Sincerely, Grete Samsa.
我知道自儿时起，格里高尔总是做着非常生动的飞行梦，那让他早晨醒来感到快乐。要是他自己能知道就好了，我一直这么想。无论如何，亲爱的医生，我认为你应该知道我可怜的哥哥发生了什么，并感谢你代表他所做的一切努力。如果你发现自己曾经在布拉格，请认为我们的家随时欢迎你。诚挚地，格蕾特·萨姆沙。
That story was written by David Rakoff, who was Seuss, and Jonathan Goldstein, who was Samsa. David has got a new book coming out next year, a novel written completely in rhyme. Jonathan's new book, I'll Seize the Day Tomorrow , comes out in October.
那个故事由大卫·拉科夫（他扮演苏斯）和乔纳森·戈德斯坦（他扮演萨姆沙）编写。大卫明年将出版一本新书，一本完全用韵文写成的小说。乔纳森的新书《我明天就占领这一天》将于十月上市。
Our program was produced today by Sarah Koening with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer's Julie Snyder. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condin's our office manager. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis, production help from [? Tariq Fudha ?].
我们的节目今天由萨拉·科宁（Sarah Koenig）制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、乔纳森·门吉瓦（Jonathan Menjivar）、莉萨·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）参与。高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）是运营总监。艾米丽·康丁（Emily Condin）是办公室经理。音乐协助来自达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）和罗布·格迪斯（Rob Geddis），制作协助来自[？Tariq Fudha？]。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our Dr. Seuss/Gregor Samsa story was produced by Jonathan Goldstein and Mira Burt-Wintonick with Cristal Duhaime. It first aired on CBC's great program WireTap , which is distributed in the United States by PRI, Public Radio International. It's also available for download online.
我们的“苏斯医生/格里高尔·萨姆沙”故事由乔纳森·戈德斯坦和米拉·伯特-温托尼克（Mira Burt-Wintonick）及克里斯塔尔·杜海姆（Cristal Duhaime）制作。它首次在加拿大广播公司的精彩节目《WireTap》中播出，该节目由公共广播国际（PRI）在美国分发。它也可以在线下载。
A program note, last week here on the radio show, we asked you to email, phone, or tweet at your local movie theater to ask them to book our upcoming film, Sleepwalk with Me . Thanks to you, we have now added 24 new theaters-- nearly doubles the number of theaters that we're at. We jumped from 34 theaters to 58, which means that we only need another-- hold on, let me-- 4,291 theaters to catch up to The Avengers .
节目预告，上周在我们的广播节目中，我们请大家给当地影院发邮件、打电话或发推特，要求他们排映我们即将上映的电影《梦游跟我来》（Sleepwalk with Me）。多亏了你们，我们现在增加了24家新影院——几乎使我们影院的数量翻了一番。我们从34家影院增加到了58家，这意味着我们只需要再……等等，让我算算……还需要4291家影院才能追上《复仇者联盟》。
You can see the trailer at our website. See it for yourself. The film was written and directed by and stars Mike Birbiglia based on a story that he did here on the radio. It's sincere. It's really funny. It killed at Sundance, came home with an audience award. We would love for you to be able to see the film with a crowd, which is the best way to see any comedy, in a theater. A list of where we are booked now and the phone numbers, email addresses, and Twitter handles of theaters near you where we want to be is at our website, thisamericanlife.org.
你可以在我们的网站看到预告片。自己看看吧。这部电影由迈克·比比利亚（Mike Birbiglia）编剧、导演并主演，基于他在电台讲述的一个故事。它很真诚。真的很搞笑。它在圣丹斯电影节大获成功，带回了观众奖。我们很乐意让你能和一群人在影院里看这部电影，这是看任何喜剧的最佳方式。目前排映的影院名单，以及你想让我们出现的地点的影院电话号码、电子邮件地址和推特账号，都在我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org 上。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know he took a tour of the White House this week. And incredibly, there in the hallway, he actually met Barack Obama.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际分发。WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督来自我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道他这周去白宫参观了。不可思议的是，在走廊里，他竟然见到了贝拉克·奥巴马。
And I just burst into tears. And I started saying, begging him, "Can I stay with you? I can cook. I could help you do blah, blah, blah. Please help me."
我只是泪如雨下。我开始说，求他，“我能和你住在一起吗？我会做饭。我可以帮你做这个那个。求你帮帮我。”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到《美国生活》带来更多故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。